one of the things i want to talk about
is what you just described
is a model for building a business that
the investor's perception of it changed
the model has always worked right you've
shown that um
but the way that companies are built is
going to change as you're describing as
well
and so whether that's the way we fund
the companies or the way that we acquire
users the way that teams work from
kind of a productivity standpoint remote
versus not like how do you think about
the big trends there of what's going to
change and
let's maybe kind of focus on like what
do you think is almost
guaranteed to change versus the things
that people are like ah you know one
percent chance it might change but if it
changes it'll have a huge impact on the
world
but what are the guaranteed changes uh
i think the one guarantee i see is that
the cost
of uh labor
of any kind is gonna go down
that's guaranteed we're probably going
to see that hit
on labor costs and the people's ability
to make money
uh go down for the next five or ten
years we see it's cyclical
it happens every time [ __ ] hits the fan
so to speak i don't know how many
shits have hit the fan this time uh so
you know and how many more might come
but my count is about three to five
depending on how you think about chained
reactions but
i was just reading a paper earlier today
um that was talking about we don't even
know the long term
impact it was a whole study on that that
just came out this morning
and i'm like okay well and it you know
i'd throw it back at you be like what do
you know because you probably have a
whole different lens that i do
but i think from a building business
operator standpoint
the cost of hiring people is going to go
down
the funny thing is the cost of marketing
i think is going to go up
and you can almost guarantee that and
that's just
the cost of every marketing channel or
tactic
or approach to marketing has
consistently always gone up
especially compared to when it fir when
a channel first starts
and these are things i think about a lot
having seen so many different marketing
channels
evolve and sort of cost more over time
and i don't just mean like channels
where like you can pay for the traffic
like facebook ads or something like that
i even mean things like you know
how easy it was to get on diggs home
page back in the day
and how much harder it got over time as
a bunch of us figured it out and started
monetizing our the attention we had on
there you're seeing the same with
twitter and things like that as well
where
i think twitter is a fascinating one
because the paid side of it has never
really worked
out and i don't know if it ever will but
the organic sort of
social media ish aspect of it is
incredible
in terms of reach and brand building and
all that stuff so
my theory is that uh and this is like
tried and true if you talk to any
marketer that like
every channel gets costly over time and
it gets harder and harder to keep your
costs down
and because you have to learn new tricks
because what happens is as people hop
onto the channel
more tactics are utilized they get
drowned out they get copied
i mean this is this is marketing right
it happens all the time the good news is
there's new channels and new effective
ways to even merge channels together to
make things work
uh so that you can keep cost down but
that means that the sophistication level
of your sort of marketing and your mix
and all that stuff goes up so
uh what's not going to change is i think
for a long time
costs of labor any kind of labor is
going to go down
there's many reasons for that one of the
main ones being people
are now used to not having to work from
an office
like just people meaning everybody
they're they're used to it whether they
like it or not like it or whether their
kids are home and all that
i'm not talking about that they're just
used to it because they have to do it
business wouldn't work
if all of us couldn't figure this out we
figured it out
i mean in fact like i have some really
good data that shows that like there's a
massive spike
in people looking for zoom sort of
uh zoom-like product video conferencing
products
that spike has completely died and it's
back to the normal levels that it was so
it's literally like
and then like came down over the last
like three or four months
and so revenues of some of the sort of
newer players
spiked and are now kind of at a more
steady pace
obviously they captured whatever they
were going to capture and now there's a
lot more to do i've seen
jumps in arr of like 5x for some of
these companies
not counting zoom even just some of the
smaller ones and when you think of it
like that
it's like we've gotten used to it that's
my point like the buying cycle like
we've gotten used to it you can look at
software buying cycles see what we've
gotten used to
we've got used to that which means that
we're probably going to be able to hire
people from anywhere
a lot more than we were used to as a
society as a whole i mean i've been
working remotely for 17 years
i used to say i don't wish it upon
anybody now it's upon
everybody right and and a lot of the
things that i do i feel like
for myself and my businesses i don't
like being dogmatic about recommending
it as
what someone else should do because i
think people are different the way they
want to work
the way they want to do things are
different for example i give one before
i
kind of uh sort of you know stop on this
one is like
i am super surprised at the
amount of zoom fatigue and complaining
about it
and the reason i'm surprised about it is
because you can turn
off the video you can just turn off the
video i mean
i was doing this stuff back in again i'm
going to date myself
but back in the day 17 years ago i'd hop
on a skype
and hit the voice button or whatever
they had because they didn't have video
and just talk to someone
i did not lose anything i have
relationships from back then of people
i've worked with for three or four
companies
i barely met them in person some of them
i've never met in person
right at my new company i'm trying to
think who have i met in person
there's i think only two people out of a
15
person company that i've met in person
one's my co-founder
and the others are head of engineering
that i've worked with across three
companies for eight years
but i haven't seen him in like two years
or a year and a half in person
right but we don't get out video calls
unless like they're with the whole team
or something it's usually like
voice so anyway what i think is
happening is
that there is the way of working is
completely gonna change
and it changed because we got a big shot
in the arm and now we have to do things
and the implications of that
are the first one being i think
because of the other factors that are
that are kind of happening in the world
labor is going to be cheaper and then
when you add in remote work and
companies like being super cool with it
now compared to what they were four
months ago five months ago
things are gonna be cheaper to build
cheaper to make cheaper to do things
yeah and so i guess one of the things
that's interesting about this is
uh of course marketing gets more
expensive the cost of
building goes down uh also there seems
to be this trend of education where
there's more and more people who have
the skills necessary to
write code market whatever we see do
does that ultimately lead to more
innovation
or is it hard to predict just because we
have more people who are skilled more
people who are educated
on these certain bodies of work it
doesn't necessarily actually lead to
more successful companies
i like the question
i think back to your prior if you take
the prior thesis of like look
there's there was like a much clearer
way
where it was one path to build a large
business which was you raise money
now there's a second way which is don't
raise any money figure it out yourself
so we the explosion of self-funded
companies
is immense it's incredible so i think
there are going to be more
successful companies in the eyes of the
operators
so a vc might look at a certain company
making a couple million bucks a year
never going to make more money or
maybe we'll make four in ten years right
go from two to four in ten years
but the operator if the operator is
operating with a less than
510 person company like there and is
happy with that
sort of growth i mean
they could take home a million bucks 2
million bucks right in the next 10 years
every freaking year it's like the new
like um
it's like the new uh doctor's office
it's like the new dentist it's like the
new
uh sort of small business basically is
all these
self-funded software businesses in every
niche every category and this is
happening
there's gonna be way more of that are
those companies
innovative very rarely almost never
because they don't have the r d budget
if you want to call it that to go throw
into innovation
prior to revenue so innovation happens
at a slower pace and over time
if you look at sort of most of the
innovation that's out there
the fact that more people are skilled
you would assume that there would be
more innovation i think there's gonna
there's gonna be not as much increase in
innovation as we might have expected
because there's a lot more sort of um
mimicking copycatting
at best being inspired and we see very
little sort of
creativity around the solution that
you're trying to
sort of uh build for a customer because
if you can solve it
without innovation why wouldn't you
right and in fact all this knowledge
makes you makes people think more like
that
because like well we can try that thing
over there we could try that thing over
there
it's not our thing it might work in our
market it's a different market we're
going to try the thing
and and and the ability to see what
everyone's doing
is something that people don't talk
about as much as
as sort of other things so like for
example i think the thing that's changed
dramatically is like the tooling to like
see
which apps are charting in the different
app stores
that's like new stuff it's five years
old like it's not 10 years old
and so our ability to see what other
people are doing and
imitate it has increased our skill set
that means in my opinion needs to be a
lot lower or can be a lot lower to
achieve the same amount of
sort of growth or or create the same
amount of
sort of value uh just because the
knowledge is all out there and the
ability to see what another company's
doing is like
you snap your finger you can go look at
a lot of their publicly available data
and there's a lot of it that's available